hello everyone and welcome to the
quarterfinals of the fiji world cup 2021
it's a atm backroad vs magnus cross and
this is their first classical game and
this is well i think the best game so
far of the
of the tournament at least uh if we only
uh you know take
into consideration the classical games
uh because it's uh well it's
just uh super enjoyable uh you're gonna
see what what i mean by this uh
okay maybe you already saw the game i
didn't upload it
immediately after it finished but you
know i can't always upload it
immediately after it finishes sometimes
there are other things to do
uh that being said uh let's check out
the game and uh
yes uh like i said it's good it's gonna
be a really awesome one uh so at the end
here
opens with e4 we have e5 by magnus
sorry about that we have knight to f3
uh knight to c6 and bishop to b5 going
for the roy lopez with a6 morphy's
defense bishop to a4 and now
knight to f6 we have castles bishop to
e7 and
rook to e1 so all very standard stuff we
see this pretty much every day
we have b5 bishop to b3 and here magnus
castles
uh and now we have a4 this is the
so-called anti-martial move because if
you play c3 and now you want to prepare
to
strike in the center black can just play
d5 and then black will have
the the full blown martial attack on the
board which is super enjoyable for black
and
well every top player enjoys playing it
so of course
etienne wants to avoid this against
magnus he goes for a4
the so-called anti-martial variation and
now bishop to b7 by magnus we have d3
and d6 now bishop to d2 uh
and here comes queen to d7 so the queen
is now developed the rooks are
connected uh we have knights to c3 and
now
knight to a5 the standard lopez move
attacking the light square bishop
while preparing to grab more space here
with c5
so bishop to a2 of course back row wants
to
uh say save his light square bishop and
now uh
we have c5 as planned so black really
grabbed a lot of space here knights the
e2 now preparing c3 to grab
some space in the center and now comes
knight back to c6 so now
you will be able to for example bring
the knight to d4 it's uh it's a great
outpost
for the uh and here we have knight the
g3
now it's a very interesting this
position has been reached before it was
reached in
the 1967 regio emilia tournament
that was won by milan matulovic and also
it was
in his game that this position was
reached he played against sergio marott
and uh matulo which won that game where
black continued with the g6 but here
magnus doesn't play g6 magnus plays d5
and it is now
only as of move 14 that we have a
completely new game
and now it seems that magnus is so
strong that he is able to play the
martial attack against
the anti-martial setup so let's let's
see what happens here
with e captures on the e5 magnus
captures on d5 and now
okay you can't grab the pawn right away
because if you grab it right away then
bishop to f6 and you will win back your
pawn so
and that's something you want to do so
here we have c3 by at the end
and now rook 8 d8 and now the
pawn is uh well definitely up for for
grabs and at the end grabs it so knight
captures on e5
uh but not right away of course first
you grab the b5 pawn captures captures
and now
knight captures an e5 knight captures
rook captures and now
bishop to d6 so now getting uh sort of a
weird
martial setup here where uh the your
bishop pair is fully operational uh your
uh well queen is ready to get into the
game and the
the rooks are very easily activatable so
here we have rook back to e1
and now knight to f4 and okay magnus is
down upon but he has some very nice
threats here he's attacking the g2 pawn
twice uh by the bishop and by the knight
and also just threatening to capture on
d3
so you really have to capture this
knight there's no way around it and the
white has to give up the bishop pair so
bishop captures an f4
we have bishop captures on f4 and now
again
this pawn is hanging if etienne doesn't
want to part with it he has to do
something and he finds a very nice
knight to e4
uh d4 was also maybe a possibility as uh
you know
just trying to you know keep it equal
but trying to keep it equal
while someone is attacking you usually
means that you're going to lose the game
so here after knight to e4 we have queen
to c7
uh now you could trade of course
captures and then knight captures here
but magnus wants to
you know keep this an attacking game he
doesn't want to go after pawns
so uh just queen to c7 defending while
also attacking on h2 and now
etienne has to decide whether he's going
to defend with the queen for example or
he's going to block the bishop with the
g3
he decides for pawn to g3 also
kind of makes uh some reading room for
the king but not really because now the
light square bishop is a monster
uh we have bishop back to e5 and now
comes
f4 attacking the bishop here and now
magnus just goes back
bishop to d6 and uh even though
you could capture this bishop with the
knight you really don't gain anything
this
the dark square bishop is no longer your
problem your problem now is the light
square bishop so giving up the central
knight for this bishop
uh really really does nothing and this
knight is
you know quite a quite a good defender
here so here we have queen the h5
now uh putting some pressure on on
carlson's king side
uh but now magnus just placed queen to
c6
and now you can never move this knight
otherwise uh you're you're getting
checkmated
there was also a very interesting move
c4 just blocking the light square bishop
attacking the d3 pawn and once
white advances it now we play f5 attack
the knight here
knight g5 threatening checkmate h6
pushing the knight back now knight f3
and now queen c6 so we get this position
instead of that one
uh kind of a similar position also
happened in the game but now it's uh
the bishop really does nothing here the
rook okay the rook is on the open e file
but other than that
not very useful the knight cannot move
because of checkmate to the queen
also not doing all that much so it would
be it would be a
pretty great position for black but okay
magnus found something similar he played
queen to c6 right away
and now queen back to h3 of course you
have to
uh be ready to somehow try and defend
but it's not easy if the knight moves
you also have queen to h1 so
okay the king will always be able to
move to f2 so at least they're not
getting checkmated
so here now magnus plays c4 and now the
light square bishop is out of the game
for the moment
we have d4 and now rook d the e8
uh just shifting the attack over here to
the knight now
the knight is attacked three times and
there really is no good move here for
example if etienne just
captures the bishop here okay you're not
getting checkmated but still
just queen captures and there's no way
for white to do anything you can't
really double up on the e file because
well there's nothing to double up with
uh
you can't bring the queen into the game
this the entire diagonal is covered by
the bishop queen to c6 is coming once
again
so it's gonna be uh really a problematic
um
position to defend uh for for uh for
white
uh but okay uh here we have d5 uh going
for a different idea now blocking the
uh queen and bishop battery here and
preparing rook eight to d1
if magnus accepts the pawn so magnus
calculates precisely he accepts the pawn
now again there is the threat of just
rook captures on e4
but now atm plays rook eight to d1
attacks carlson's queen
but this is probably why magnus went for
uh for the the line that we discussed
instead of the the immediate c4 line
feel free to pause the video here and
try to figure out what magnets had in
mind
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations uh on
finding uh well a move that simply has
to be played
if you are to you know push for
something here and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the
show it's rook captures an e4 we grab
the knight and we offer our queen
so the the queen has to be accepted
otherwise you're just dead lost so rook
captures on d5
but now rook captures an e1 with check
we have king to f2
and now another very interesting
position uh because
well your rook is under attack but also
white is just attacking your bishop here
so how do you defend here
well there is one move that really gives
a black advantage and that is
rook f2e8 so now you see that
the bishop cannot be captured and our
rook is defended because if the bishop
is captured
just a rook coming to e2 will be
checkmated the bishop is preventing the
king from escaping via the f3 square
so after rook after e8 we have rook to
e5
uh this has to be played there is no
other way also the bishop just attacks
the rook here so it's a pretty
pretty uh you know
bad square for this rook but now uh here
we have bishop captures on e5 by magnus
also very interesting was just rook
captures on e5 and keeping the bishop
paired this way but not this rook
obviously read this rook because
otherwise
the king would capture rook and e1 and
now after f captures then
we get bishop to c5 check and now our
bishop pair is
really really uh just beautiful here for
example king f1 bishop the e4 going to
d3
and it's gonna be well very hard for uh
for white to defend this but
magnus played bishop captures an e5 here
now
of course if you capture then rook
captures and we are just completely
winning so you have to capture the rook
uh there is no other way
but now bishop captures on c3 uh with uh
with a double check we have king to f1
and now uh you have to be very careful
if your bishop is
attacked here if you just go back then
queen to d7 wins the game for white the
rook and the bishop are attacked there's
no defending this if rook to be
ifrook the ba just queen here and we win
the game
so here magnus finds the only move that
continues
to give black advantage and that is
bishop the c8 we attack the queen and
now
our bishop is safe there queen back to
g2
and now another very nice idea of bishop
to f5
so what do you play here well obviously
you could capture the bishop here but if
you capture the bishop then you get this
bishop to d3 check
and where do you go if you go to g1
that's a problem if you go to g2 that's
also a problem the rook just uh
wins the game for example kg1 rook to e1
check now you have to go back king of
two rookie two checks so the king always
ends up on f2 uh and then we win the
queen
and of course the game once the king
moves let's say king of three we're
gonna capture captures and now of course
it's a win
winning end game at the bishop here is
completely out of the game there is no
move here that white can even consider
playing
so after bishop f5 we have queen to d5
uh activating the queen like this
attacking the bishop on f5
but now bishop back to e6 attacking the
queen and again you can't go after the
b5 pawn because if you capture the b5
pawn
uh then you you run into bishop to h3
check and the rook is controlling this
the bishop this
uh so your only option is either g1 and
then bishop to d4 check uh
ends the game uh or king to f2 but still
bishop to d4 check king to f3
now rook the e3 check and there are no
squares other than the f2 square you
have to go
in front of the mask of the bishop and
then uh just uh
uh rook b3 a discovery uh from the
bishop and
white loses the queen so after bishop to
e6 uh you can't grab the pawn queen to
c5
by etienne and now bishop captures on b2
and now it's a problem because now
magnus has a
beautiful pass pawn okay he has two past
pawns but
it's very unlikely that both of them
will survive we have king to g2
and now bishop to d7 just uh
defending this pawn again if you just
grab the pawn
it's not much better you run into the
same bishop to h3 idea that we just
discussed
so after bishop captures on b2 king g2
not allowing this square for the bishop
no longer
so bishop to d7 magnus defends the pawn
and now comes queen to d5 and here
etienne
had a chance to play queen to c7 it
seems
pretty you know similar uh both moves
kind of attack the bishop here but it's
not because after queen to d5 magnus has
rook to d8 and this is just uh removing
the threat
while introducing one bishop to h3 again
becomes a threat uh
as well you're going to win the queen if
white does nothing
so here etienne has to go back queen to
c5 and now
the show back to f6 and now both of your
pawns are protected and you are ready to
start pushing them
so what can ntn do bishop to b1 finally
the bishop is released from its tomb
but g6 now uh we have g4
and now uh what do you play here here uh
the g4 pawn is being offered for for the
b5 pawn
but magnus says that's a pretty good
deal i only need one pass pawn so he
eliminates this one
queen captures on b5 and now c3 the pass
pawn is
marching forward we have f5 now trying
to open up the the black king side
but now magnus just played g5 and it was
in this position on mu 44 that etienne
bakr resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh and
that that definitely is true because
whatever white
tries it simply uh will not be enough uh
to give you an example
uh for example uh yeah okay that sounds
weird but
uh you know what i mean so let's say
queen b6 we attack the bishop and the
rook white has to play something we're
just going to play king to g7 now the
bishop guards the rogue the king guards
the bishop so
what other resources are there for white
you could try king g3
attacking the bishop but then just h5 we
defend it
and there are no more moves you can play
to introduce any threats because
everything is defended and you can only
wait uh you know for your doom let's say
queen e3
we're going to play rook to d2 now
threat c2
so that's also going to be completely
winning so let's say bishop d3
not allowing this to come with an attack
on the bishop now we just play bishop to
d1
and now this king really has no squares
the king controls this the pawns control
this
uh it's very very unpleasant white
there's really no move that white can
make for example queen e4 we make a move
just h4 check
king to h3 and now g4 and that's it you
don't uh
you you don't really have a move here uh
you you're going to have to give up the
queen
and that's not not very very very very
fun
uh so yeah after g5 uh etienne resigned
and what uh what a great victory for
magnus carlson who successfully employed
the martial attack
against the anti-martial setup which is
which is very very incredible
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it really an awesome one
especially for a classical game so
uh really hoping uh for a great one
today we'll see if at the end uh we'll
be able to bounce back in the second
game and force tie breaks
um regarding the other games uh um
oh well dude avid attended in a draft
tabata
also ended in a draw uh and the karakan
shankland uh i will not
disclose that one uh maybe some of you
haven't seen it
but it uh may have not ended in a draw
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank uh
psp artist love lubelski matthew benoit
vladolaro lu studio cindario pavlovic
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
beautiful tournament until it finishes
uh thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day